die aktuellen Zahlen zur Wirtschaft sind
schlecht jetzt meldete das Statistische
Bundesamt noch einen Produktionsrückgang
bei deutschen Unternehmen im Juni um
1,5%. unter anderem Bürokratie
Fachkräftemangel und hohe Energiekosten
infolge auch der ehrgeizigen
Energiewende lähmen die deutsche
Wirtschaft die Beratungsfirma sentics
bezeichnet Deutschland als kranken Mann
Eurolands auch politisch ist das Thema
nun oben als das einzige Industrieland
auf der Welt befindet sich Deutschland
im Jahr 2023 in der Rezession und das
hat etwas mit der deutschen
Wirtschaftspolitik zu tun und da fordert
die Union nun unter anderem eine Senkung
von Stromsteuer Netzentgelten und
Grunderwerbsteuer einen Stopp weiterer
Bürokratie und auch das heizungsgesetzes
und bessere Abschreibungen Grüne und SPD
wollen eher ein staatliches
Investitionsprogramm und den
industriestrompreis die FDP will vor
allem Steuerentlastungen und keine
Subventionen oder kurzfristigen
Konjunkturprogramme die AFD den Stopp
der Energiewende die Linke einer Reform
der Schuldenbremse zwei Fachleute
fordern langfristiges Denken die
Bundesregierung muss gute
Rahmenbedingungen für
Zukunftsinvestitionen setzen Subvention
per Gießkanne an Unternehmen ausschütten
das wäre der falsche Weg also kein
Konjunkturprogramm sondern ein kluges
Transformationsprogramm ich glaube wir
müssen ganz dringend davon wegkommen und
nur um die kurze Frist Gedanken zu
machen sozusagen nur an die nächsten
Bundestagswahlkampf zu denken sondern
wir müssen strukturell langfristig
vorbauen das Energie zur Verfügung steht
dass die Standortbedingungen gut sind
das Bildungssystem gut ist und
Fachkräfte zur Verfügung stehen Richtung
grüne bedeutet dies mit staatsprogramm
und industriestrompreis ist es eher
nicht getan
ja jetzt haben die Grünen allerdings
genau das vorgelegt einen fünf
Punkteplan mit Milliarden schweren
Investitionsprogramm sprechen wir
darüber mit Katharina dröge der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen im Bundestag einen schönen guten
Morgen aus Berlin
schönen guten Morgen Frau dröge sie
haben ganz frisch einen fünf Punkte Plan
mit Investitionen unter anderem in
Zukunft Technologie sozialen Wohnungsbau
und Infrastruktur vorgelegt ohne jetzt
auf jedes Detail einzugehen ich glaube
das würde hier unseren Rahmen sprengen
wo liegt ihr Schwerpunkt
also die deutsche Wirtschaft ist stark
aufgestellt aber tatsächlich ist die
Investitionstätigkeit der deutschen
Unternehmen zu gering und deswegen sagen
wir als grüne Bundestagsfraktion dass
wir auf der einen Seite in den 2020er
Jahren für wettbewerbsfähige Strompreise
sorgen müssen solange bis die
Erneuerbaren wirklich effektiv die
Preise senken und deswegen braucht es
einen industriestrompreis der das
garantiert und auf der anderen Seite ist
gerade das Baugewerbe aufgrund der hohen
Zinsen und der Lieferengpässe in einer
nicht so guten Situation und wenn man
die energetische Gebäudesanierung
deutlich stärker fördern würde und den
sozialen Wohnungsbau deutlich stärker
fördern würde dann würde man hier ein
doppelten Effekt schaffen auf der einen
Seite gut für Klima und Gerechtigkeit
auf der anderen Seite gut fürs Handwerk
und Jobs da sagen wir mit 30 Milliarden
Euro eine Impuls zu geben das ist jetzt
das richtige Signale dieser Zeit gut
einzelne Punkte wie den
industriestrompreis besprechen wir
gleich noch mal in detail aber
vielleicht vorweg noch mal die Frage
dass die Grünen jetzt so auf Wirtschaft
setzen ist das eigentlich ihr versucht
Vertrauen zurück zu gewinnen den
Menschen also zu zeigen wir denken nicht
nur ans Klima sondern auch an
Unternehmen an Jobs an Wohlstand
wir haben ja im gesamten letzten Jahr
genau daran gearbeitet dass dieses Land
weiterhin gut aufgestellt ist es war der
Riesen Verdienst von Robert Habeck dass
wir die Energieversorgung sicher konnten
nachdem die CDU und so stark in die
Abhängigkeit von Russland gebracht hat
und dass die deutsche Industrie so gut
da steht das ist eben genau das
Verdienst von Robert Habeck und jetzt
geht es darum die Zukunftsfähigkeit der
deutschen Wirtschaft sicherzustellen und
da legen wir natürlich ein Schwerpunkt
drauf als Grüne in dieser Regierung
Wirtschaftsvertreter das wissen selber
auch warten bereits in letzter Zeit vor
grüner d-industriealisierung ihre
Zustimmungswerte sind innerhalb von
einem Jahr von 23 auf 14%
runtergerutscht die Akzeptanz für
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen sind also das sind
doch alles Gründe Pläne und
Kommunikation jetzt schon auf andere
Schwerpunkte zu lenken
also gerade in der Frage wie wir unsere
Wirtschaft zukunftsfähig aufstellen sehe
ich einen absolut breites Angebot an die
Menschen in diesem Land weil jeder fragt
sich ja gerade Wie geht's mit meinem Job
in Zukunft weiter wie kann ich meine
Miete bezahlen deswegen auch die
Konzentration auf das Thema sozialer
Wohnungsbau und auch was durch gegen
hohe Energiepreise und da ist die
energetische Gebäude Sanierung ein ganz
wichtiger Schritt deswegen ja dieser
Dreiklang mit dem ich glaube dass wir
wirklich für viele Menschen in diesem
Land auch die richtige Antwort bieten 30
Milliarden Euro schwer soll ihr
Investitionsprogramm ja sein woher kommt
das Geld
wir haben im letzten Jahr mit dem
Wirtschafts- und Stabilisierungsfonds
eine kreditermächtigung ergriffen die
genau für die Krise ausgerichtet war
also gegen hohe Energiepreise zu
Stabilisierung der Wirtschaft und dort
ist noch Spielraum weil wir so gut mit
vorgesorgt haben im letzten Jahr mit den
gasbeschaffungen ist dann noch ein
Volumen zur Verfügung und wir schlagen
vor diese kreditermächtigung aus dem
Wirtschafts- und stabilisierungs
insbesondere jetzt hierfür auch zu
nutzen haben Sie denn darüber auch schon
mit Christian Lindner gesprochen
wir sind tatsächlich in der
Bundesregierung im Austausch miteinander
und es gibt noch unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen das ist auch normal in so
einer Zeit mit drei unterschiedlichen
Parteien aber uns eigentlich alle das
gemeinsame Ziel dass wir jetzt antworten
zu investitionsstärkung gegeben werden
und dass wir auch zeitnah bis zum Ende
des Sommers zu gemeinsamen Lösungen
kommen wollen gut ein Streitpunkt ist
und bleibt über definitiv die Diskussion
um den industriestrompreis der ja Teil
ihres Plans ist wie sie sagen
energieintensive Betriebe sollen also
von subventionierten Strompreisen
profitieren das Lernen Scholz und
Lindner ganz strikt ab Brot da also
weiter Streit
also die Industrie selber und auch die
Gewerkschaften fordern seit langem
wettbewerbsfähige Industriepreise und
deswegen hat Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
schon vor einigen Wochen den Vorschlag
gemacht für die 2020er Jahre die
Industriepreise zu deckeln wir sehen
gerade in den USA mit welcher
Entschlossenheit Joe Biden ein grünes
industrieprogramm vorlegt und wir müssen
das aus unserer Sicht hier in Europa
auch beantworten damit weiterhin die
Produktion gerade für
Zukunftstechnologien hier in Deutschland
in Europa bleibt und ich denke das sind
gute Argumente mit denen wir die
Koalitionspartner auch überzeugen können
Frau dröge die Befürchtung ist doch
schon dass wenn Firmen von
subventionierten Preisen profitieren
geht der Anreiz selbst in
Energieeffizienz zu investieren total
verloren also da würde sich die Katze
schon in den Schwanz beißen haben sie
diese Sorge gar nicht
der Vorschlag macht zielt genau darauf
aus dass nicht wie gesamte Summe des
Energieverbrauchs mit einem gedeckelten
preisversehen wird sondern das weiterhin
in seinem Konzept auch Energiespar
Anreize mit enthalten sind und deswegen
ist es gerade so ein kluger Vorschlag
der auf der einen Seite bezahlbare
Strompreise Sicherheit aber auf der
anderen Seite eben auch Energie einspar
Anreize setzt und die Unternehmen selber
haben ja aufgrund von hohen
Energiekosten auch den Anreiz möglichst
effizient mit ihrer Energie umzugehen
sagt die Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen
im Bundestag Katharina dröge ganz
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen